I saw the movie last night I was blown
away
I think it's spectacular I really did I
loved it and I loved your performance
Hugh Jackman's great in it and it is
it's terrific action and also very
poignant mm-hmm yeah that's all the time
we've got good night everybody
that would do just fine yeah well we're
very pleased yeah actually that's we're
very proud of this movie yeah because
it's breaking ground in the superhero
movie I mean how many times in a
superhero movie do you see six people
sitting around a family table just
having dinner yes and talking right it
of course proceeds something that's very
unpleasant yeah
there are seems like that my first scene
with you in the movies six or seven
pages of dialogue with things happen
between us but it's about the
relationships just as much as it is
about yeah yeah is that what you do
whenever you see Hugh Jackman ah he
loves that
yeah
you know I did notice that in the film
Hugh Jackman has to work really hard
your character your terrific actor
you're in a wheelchair throughout the
the film Hugh Jackman there are many
scenes where he has to pick you up and
it looks like yeah Hugh Jackman is just
picking up and carrying you through half
the movie yeah it's not that impressive
you're not impressed by that oh oh I was
actually now I'm Jeff that was just a
mild little remark to lead up to the
fact that I lost 20 plus pounds before I
shot this movie partly because I wanted
to look you know emaciated and ill and
old which Charles Xavier is in this
movie yeah but I was also thinking a
little bit about mr. Jackman and you
know there is one moment and it's not
done with a cut there's no camera tricks
or anything I'm lying on the floor and
he bends down and picks me up and puts
me back in my bed he carries me upstairs
Downstairs narrow very steep stairs I
was never afraid or alarmed he takes me
to the toilet and I wasn't that was even
part of the movie well yeah you're right
it wasn't part of it so good put it in
the movie
but how often do you see a scene like
that I mean I you don't see anything you
just hear me say let me do that yes yes
yeah you want a little privacy at that
moment don't we want yes yes well
whenever Wolverine takes me to the
bathroom I want privacy those things yes
Gary oh when he wanted to get mad yeah
he offers to get the zipper I'm like no
you were you watched Logan for the first
time with Hugh Jackman and without you
know this is a very emotional movie
because you two have played these two
characters many times and things are
really your characters are really
getting backed into a corner here was
watching that film with him emotional it
was very emotional we were in Berlin at
the film festival and by the way a great
piece of a compliment to the film that
it was invited to Berlin because they
don't show movies like that very often
right we were not in competition we got
to the last few minutes of the movie and
my part in the movie was over that's all
I'm allowed to say right and we were
sitting side by side and we got into
those final moments and I suddenly felt
something and Hugh had taken my hand and
was squeezing it and then I saw his hand
come up and do this and I thought damn
it if Hugh Jackman can weep at the
Berlin Film Festival so can i that's all
right
so you're admitting you felt nothing oh
he's crying he's showing human emotion I
squeeze something out right now maybe
not don't have those knives I got
you